[Music]
it's time for our monthly meetup Sony
have once again unveiled the PlayStation
Plus games for the month of August 2019
this bad boys will be available from the
first Tuesday of the month which is the
6th of August so if you're ready let's
get on with this
first up is a sniping master class a
bullet time extravaganza
this is Sniper Elite 4 in this
third-person tactical shooter we are
stuck behind enemy lines and the only
way out is to use the environment to our
advantage
tripwires explosive barrels and the
greatest use of x-ray in the history of
video games watching bullets penetrate
your foes destroying their organs and
breaking their bones so satisfying known
as a single-player game the unsung
element of Sniper Elite 4 which has the
most fun in my opinion is the
cooperative campaign there's nothing
better than removing a Nazi regime with
your best mate Dave Sniper Elite 4
boasts 12 player online multiplayer
matches to perfect your hips and timing
reviews range from about 7 to about 8
and a half out of 10 making this and
must play so come on are you going to
try it if you can handle blood this is a
great game game number 2 is a racer with
an historic lineage wipeout omega
collection this is the fast paced sci-fi
racer you remember from the ps1 days but
this version of Wipeout includes
multiple games wipeout 2048 wipeout HD
and the HD fury expansion all in one
perfect package with 26 tracks to race
and ridiculously competitive online a
player matches wipeout omega collection
has something for everyone
but wait it gets better psvr users of
the world
rejoice for this version of Wipeout
fully support VR all tracks all modes so
if you'd like to give you two try motion
sickness is waiting for you so you can
grab all of this from August the 6th but
wait I have an extra for you this month
I've teamed up with Micom to show you a
free-to-play game which is downloadable
on your ps4 right now and recently had a
huge update this is skyforge an MMO
which fuses science fiction mythology
and fantasy into one package the element
which drew me to Skyforge was how it
feels to play on
troller skyforge manages to optimize
everything for controller play allowing
the action to take center stage saying
that though the cinematic cutscenes are
impressive too especially when you get
your character looking like a badass the
latest expansion New Horizons brings a
new area to the game and with this new
world comes a new enemy type the
Draconids like dragon human hybrids kind
of like my mother-in-law oh and PS Plus
subscribers of course there's added
bonuses for you such as free access to
the premium subscription service in the
game and the new class known as the
sound Weaver and yes they literally Rock
a guitar as a weapon well you guys with
PS plus you'll receive an exclusive
costume variation for free so something
for everyone if you like the PS + games
go for it if you're not too into it give
skyforge
a try instead link in the description
what are you downloading this month I'd
love to know anything you'd like me to
play on the channel just give me a shout
I'm Adam from PlayStation granade I'll
see you next time